TIM: Hi, and welcome to
Tech Tips From Teachers.
On this episode,
we'll be looking
at apps that are great
for formative assessment
in the classroom.
Our guest for this
episode is Emily Tombes
from San Jose, California.
Emily has a master's degree
in elementary education
from the University of Virginia,
and is currently a second grade
teacher.
As part of her role, she
helps to lead the curriculum
and assessment design programs
for her entire school,
and previously she
taught third grade
at a charter school that adhered
to an adaptive learning model.
So Emily, tell us a little
bit about why technology's
important in the classroom.
EMILY TOMBES: Technology
makes collaborating
with my coworkers really easy.
I use Google Docs
for planning, and I
am able to communicate what I'm
working on with my coworkers,
and we're able to share a lot
of that information online.
It helps out with
planning, and making sure
that we are able to share
data regarding the students,
and how they've scored on tests,
how they're doing on projects,
and we're able to communicate
with one another about that.
So technology makes
it a lot easier
for me to work with my
coworkers and collaborate
with them, and also to plan.
TIM: Cool.
And what about
formative assessment?
Why is that something that's
critical in the classroom?
EMILY TOMBES: Yeah, so
formative assessment
is really important for
two key reasons for me.
It's a planning tool.
When I give my kids a test
or a quick little check
for understanding, I'm
able to tell really quickly
whether they're understanding
what I'm giving them.
So I'm able to use
it for planning
and make sure that I know what
my next steps are as a teacher.
And also so that
can differentiate
for the specific needs of
my students in my class.
TIM: In speaking with
teachers about apps
that are great for
formative assessment,
we came upon a few major themes.
It's important
that these apps are
easy to manage and
implement, that they
have strong reporting, and that
they help to foster discussion
among students.
So Emily, why is it so
critical that an app is
easy for a teacher to manage?
EMILY TOMBES: As a teacher,
my time is really sacred.
There's a lot that I
need to do in the day.
When I have an app
that is easy to manage,
I can use that app to help
me create quick formative
assessments and quick
checks for understanding,
so that I don't have to
spend a whole lot of time
creating those things on my own.
TIM: And what about
that data piece.
Why is reporting so important?
EMILY TOMBES: When I
have really solid data,
I can use it for two purposes.
I use it for planning.
I can use it to see what my
students did really well with,
what they need a little bit
of support and review on,
and if I need to go back and
totally re-teach something.
So when I get data back
from those students,
I can tell what I need
to do as a teacher.
I can also look at it for
differentiation purposes.
So I can tell which
kids in my class
did really well on a certain
skill, which kids might need
a little-- just a little
bit of extra support,
and which kids need to be
in a small group with me
or with an intervention
specialist.
TIM: Gotcha.
And then what about
with discussion?
Why is that something that you'd
want to include in your class?
EMILY TOMBES: Yeah, this is
one of my favorite components
of really building a solid
formative assessment.
Because when I see the
discussion piece of an answer,
I'm able to look at the gray
area of where a kid was-- what
their thought process was
as they were coming up
with an answer.
So when I see
their discussion, I
can tell how they got
to their answer, maybe
some misconceptions
that they might have,
and what I can
target my instruction
towards the next time I
review a certain skill.
So if I have the students
discussing something,
it's a lot easier for me to tell
what their thought process was,
and what I can be
reviewing as a teacher.
TIM: Emily, let's take a look
at some apps that are really
great for formative assessment.
EMILY TOMBES: Yeah, so the
first one I want to look at
is Socrative.
And Socrative is great
because it's really easy
to implement and to manage.
As a teacher, one of
my favorite things
is that there's no
student logins needed.
Students can just join
the teacher's classroom
based on the unique code
that I receive as a teacher.
The other thing I
really like about it
is that I can create
formative assessments
in a lot of different ways.
They also have some
games that can really
engage the kids in
the process of doing
this formative assessment.
They can sort of compete
with one another.
TIM: Tell us about Exit Ticket.
EMILY TOMBES: Yeah,
so Exit Ticket's
great because it gives
me the opportunity
to use that strong reporting.
I get to look at the
Exit Ticket formats
to decide how my kids
did on their assessments.
I can look at very
different dashboards
and tell how they're being
successful with certain things,
and what they still
need to review.
It gives me a chance to
give assessments either
in the middle of the lesson.
I can do something called
a check for understanding,
where I look to see if
the kids are understanding
my teaching as I'm going
through the lesson.
But I can also build more
traditional Exit Tickets
at the end of the lesson,
and give them a final chance
to show me what they learned.
TIM: And what's
valuable about Verso?
EMILY TOMBES: It gives
students an opportunity
to watch a video,
or look at a task
and respond to a task
in a discussion format.
So they log in and they
write their responses
in more conversational tone.
They can "like" each
other's comments.
They can comment on
one another's comments,
and it just allows that
discussion piece to continue.
It does offer me
accountability as a teacher
so I can log in and
see which students
are posting the discussions.
And I get a chance to see which
students are participating,
which students might need
a little push in class
to participate more.
In the formative
assessment component,
it allows me, as
the teacher, to see
what parts are very present
in their discussions,
and what components I
need to go back and really
push them to be thinking
about, as they're
posting their answers and
posting their comments.
TIM: Emily, thanks so
much for joining us today.
EMILY TOMBES: Thanks
for having me.
It was great to be here.
TIM: And to recap, a few
things to keep in mind
for formative assessment apps.
It's important that they're
easy to manage and implement,
that they have strong
reporting, and that they
help to foster discussion
among students.
For more episodes of
Tech Tips From Teachers,
check out the Google
Developers' YouTube channel.
Thanks.